producing street talk for all this time
now
has given me a deep interest and
understanding
of what it means to think and what it
means
to be intelligent machine learning
systems typically learn to approximate
functions
by relating input variables to output
variables
in a process that judea perl has likened
to curve fitting programmers on the
other hand
define their algorithms independently of
training data
purely in terms of operations over
variables
the programmers have confidence that
their programs will work in
almost all situations humans can pick up
new skills
and assimilate new knowledge with a
small amount of new information
this is the so-called kaleidoscope
effect
which is to say being able to cast
previous experience
into many new types of situations in
experience space
we do this by building new models on the
fly
by extrapolating from abstract
prior knowledge coming up later on in
the show
60 minutes we're going to try to catch
us out and prove that we uh
secretly bugged jeff and tao what's kind
of a workable definition
of abstraction going also here beyond
the buzzword of you know we need
abstraction i i do abstraction
you do abstraction like when does a
system do
abstraction and what would you accept
like if i came to you and said i have
gpt4 and it does abstraction what would
you accept
as a test that that is happening
professor gary marcus says we want
artificial intelligence
we can trust in our homes on our roads
in our doctor's offices and hospitals
in our businesses and in our communities
robust artificial intelligence while not
necessarily
superhuman or self-improving can be
counted on
to apply what it knows to a wide range
of problems
in a systematic and reliable way
synthesizing knowledge from a variety of
sources
such that it can reason flexibly and
dynamically about the world
transferring what it knows in one domain
into another context in the same way
that we would expect of an ordinary
adult
if we cannot count on our ai to behave
robustly
then we shouldn't trust it gary concedes
that we're missing some fundamental
ideas about how to deal with the
combinatorial complexity of reality
and how to integrate knowledge that we
have about the world
with learning we use a lot of abstract
knowledge
all the time but all of the intelligent
systems which have been created to date
are narrow which is to say there's
almost no
adaptation to novelty imagine a chess
algorithm that broke if you change the
board size
by one without having to retrain it from
scratch
all of the latest efforts from deepmind
would fail on this simple hurdle
i think gary really nailed it when he
said transferring what an ai learns from
one context
into another this is the fundamental
thing which ai systems today
are missing professor gary marcus is a
cognitive scientist
he views cognition as a kind of
cycle humans take in perceptual
information from the outside they build
internal and possibly incomplete
cognitive models
based on their perception of that
information and then they make
decisions with respect to those
cognitive models
gary passionately believes that if we
don't do something
analogous to this we won't succeed in
our quest
for robust intelligence though i was
brutally
repeatedly frequently attacked for it
for saying
that these systems don't abstract very
well
that there's a real problem with
extrapolating beyond the training data
that replicability was a problem that
there's no real semantics there
um etc i think all of those are now
actually received wisdom they're now in
fact if you watch
benjio's recent talks they're basically
the the
introduction to his talks are those
things that i said
and you know lacoon has turned around
even he has actually turned around
and he he's the one who brought to the
world's attention the gpt-3 suicide
example so
even like my fiercest critics have
actually turned in the last couple of
years
the iannick said it kind of amused me a
minute ago it's easy to make the
argument about semantics well no it
wasn't for 20 years
every time i made it i was accused of
being a terrorist and a bad person
whatever gary advocates for a four-step
program
the initial development of hybrid
neurosymbolic architectures
followed by construction of rich partly
innate cognitive frameworks
and large-scale knowledge databases
followed by further development of tools
for abstract reasoning over such
frameworks and ultimately
more sophisticated mechanisms for the
representation
and induction of cognitive models he
thinks that effective cognitive
architectures
are likely to look more heterogeneous
with
specialized modules he also thinks that
we're going to have to redefine what we
even mean by learning
he thinks the new modality of learning
is more abstract it will include more
language like generalizations
and would be relative to knowledge and
cognitive models
incorporating reasoning as a first-class
citizen in the process
he thinks that we've just been skipping
too many steps
we need to start with a bedrock of
cognitive primitives
like operations over variables and
attention mechanisms and then we need to
learn to recombine them
gary says that the knowledge gathered by
contemporary neural networks
remains spotty and pointillistic
arguably useful and certainly impressive
but
never quite reliable gary says that
common sense
is open-ended winning at a game of go
is entirely different to solving an
unexpected planning problem
in self-driving i'm sure that gary would
say that
self-driving car research has been an
egregious waste of time
and money it's almost criminal gary also
cites the lack of robustness of neural
networks in
respect of their training regime most
human learners learn the same knowledge
and language
despite highly varied circumstances
neural networks are sensitive even to
the order in which the information is
presented
and many other features of the training
regime there have been some really cool
ideas lately in the neural network space
but
gary thinks that stronger medicine may
be needed
to acquire represent and manipulate
abstract knowledge
and to use that knowledge in the service
of building updating
and reasoning over complex internal
models
of the external world also joining us
this evening is professor
louis lamb perhaps the most recognizable
name
in the neurosymbolic space lewis thinks
that we can integrate logical reasoning
and neural networks he thinks that we
can learn
discrete structures and thus we can
combine
the symbolic and connectionist worlds
lewis is a huge advocate of relational
learning although
discrete relations lead to gradients
which are not easy to deal with
in neural networks lewis points out that
there are already hybrid models
everywhere in production look no further
than google search for example
lewis argues that we need abstraction
we need interpretation and rigorous
semantics
as a foundation instead of just focusing
on these shallow correlations
he says that formalizing core knowledge
is still a very open problem in the
field
lewis has done a lot of really cool work
with graph neural networks by the way
he's also concerned about these tribal
divisions in the machine learning space
at the moment
do you remember pedro domingos he spoke
of the six
tribes in artificial intelligence well
it was actually five tribes i took the
liberty of adding
cybernetics as the sixth myself
unfortunately a lot of this conflict is
borne out of competition over obtaining
grant money
and powerful positions all this formal
background
is in symbolic ai you cannot ignore that
when you look at the history of computer
science as gary said
even mcculloch and pizza when they
provided perhaps one of the first neural
network models
one of the things that they shown in the
paper was how this kind of networks they
proposed
carried out boolean reasoning logical
reasoning
gary marcus and lewis lam think that we
can address the current problems in ai
using a modern set of techniques they
think that we can retain the benefits of
deep learning
but again promote rich cognitive models
to be first-class citizens like they
once were
these days the focus is primarily on
learning with these continuous geometric
models
but marcus and lam think that it must be
part of a broader
coalition which is amenable to symbols
core knowledge
and reasoning there is simply something
profoundly
missing from deep learning right now
even the most sophisticated natural
language processing models
fail to demonstrate a scintilla of
understanding we need systems that do
more than
dredge immense data sets for subtler and
subtler correlations
in order to do better and to achieve
safety and reliability
we need systems which have a rich causal
understanding of the world
and that needs to start with an
increased focus on how to represent
acquire and reason with abstract causal
knowledge
and detailed internal cognitive models
gary says that it's a fallacy to suppose
what worked reasonably well for domains
such as speech recognition and object
labeling
which largely revolve around
classification will necessarily
work reliably for language understanding
and high level reasoning
deep learning models fail to represent
the richness of the world
and lack even any understanding that an
external world
exists at all my main observation is
that both of these gentlemen are far
more moderate than i would have expected
they both seem to be advocating for a
hybrid approach but
with connectionist models as the first
class citizen the main reason for this
seems to be the
learning which is enabled with
stochastic gradient descent this is the
best thing about neural networks
the thought of exhaustively searching a
discrete program space
is enough to put chills down even the
most hardy spines
i mean personally i'm quite excited
about the work that joss tannenbaum has
been doing
going completely discreet first you know
and searching in this type 2 space
my worry is that combining symbols of
neural networks or you know a so-called
sub-symbolic or neurosymbolic approach
might mean that we end up with all of
the problems that we had with symbol
systems and
lose many of the benefits we already
know from chalet
that neural networks are only capable of
type 1 or
interpolative generalization on a
learned smooth manifold
they cannot perform type 2 or discrete
or
extrapolative generalization these
models do
seem to allow us to represent and embed
discrete data
in a learnable continuous model but what
happens then
do we lose the ability to reason
unfortunately once you project data into
a vector space
it's irreversible and undecidable
now a few commentators said that there
was an astronomical
amount of jargon in the last episode it
seems to be increasing with compound
interest
and this show might possibly be the
worst ever so we're going to try and
explain
as much of it as possible a couple of
years ago professor marcus and professor
bengio had a really famous debate where
they battled
horns it was the symbolic approach
versus the connectionist approach
it even spawned this interesting article
called marcus versus bengio
the ai debate gary marcus is the villain
we never needed i think that we both
think the other side is straw manning
our baby
so i think you're straw meaning symbols
because lots of people put probabilities
and uncertainty into symbols
i would argue that the kind of deep
learning stuff that was straight out of
the 80s which is
you know continued until like 2016 in my
view
but we could argue about that you know
just let's have a big multi-layer
perceptron let's
pile a lot of data in and hope for the
best which i don't think you believe
anymore but maybe you did at one point
that's one kind of deep learning that's
the kind of
i don't know prototype or canonical
version of deep learning
and you want to open deep learning to a
whole lot of other things and
i think at some level that's fine at
some level i think it's changing the
game
so i want to expand the umbrella of
symbols and you want to expand the
umbrella of deep learning
why don't we say let's build deep
learning symbolic systems that
expand the scope of deep learning and
expand the scope of
symbol systems look i i don't care about
the words you want to use
i'm just trying to build something that
works and that is going to
require a few simple principles to be
understood
neuroscientists have been talking about
your modulators forever you know
so just just remove from your brain the
idea that deep learning is
in 1989 mlp with feed forward connection
that is not deep learning
sorry and i do agree
that um there's uh
lots of interesting inspiration we can
get today
in in the work that's been done in kind
of science in
in in symbolic ai whenever we discuss
symbols
or symbolic approaches think of
traditional
programming code with variables and
loops
it's kind of like what powers the
world's infrastructure already
right deep learning models deliberately
assume
traditional programming even though all
the greatest technological achievements
of mankind
have relied on software utilizing
symbolic computation
deep learning has set the standard for
learning from data
but it is symbolic methods which have
set the standard
for representing and manipulating
abstractions
for discrete problems you wouldn't be
able to pass a google interview or one
of my interviews for that matter
if you are not intimately familiar with
symbolic approaches
but how can we combine symbolic
knowledge
with perceptual data in the classical
john mccarthy-esque world of ai
practitioners were only concerned with
knowledge internal models
and reasoning but if you scan almost any
of the modern day literature on
ai you won't detect a single iota
of these ideas not even a whiff
of course you can count on francois
charles and christian sergey and melanie
mitchell to bring up common sense
and reasoning but it really is slim
pickings in general
when it comes to citing rich cognitive
models
gpt-3 is the statistical language model
which perhaps
most characterizes our move away from
these classical ai
ideas since the resurgence of deep
learning in the last decade
as we discussed ad nauseam on our
special edition episode on gbt3
but if you wanted to give medical advice
and somebody tried to set this thing up
as a suicide prevention
uh counselor then it's a tragedy right
you know there's an example out there on
the web where someone asked gpt3
or said i want to kill myself and gpt3
said i think
um that would be a good idea it doesn't
have any common sense knowledge
no explicit cognitive model which could
be updated
and it cannot perform any explicit
extrapolative
or abstractive reasoning what that means
is that it wouldn't understand what jon
had sour grapes
actually meant do you remember aesop's
fable
in which a fox tries to reach some
delicious grapes
when he failed though he declared that
he didn't want them anyway because they
were sour
this is a linguistic embodiment of the
abstract mental category of situations
featuring something that is the object
of someone's arduo
but having proven out of reach is
subsequently deprecated by the person
who desired it
this abstract quality often concisely
called
sour grapes is potentially recognizable
in thousands
of situations and this phrase could be
thus
used as the verbal label on any such
situation
gpt 3 doesn't understand the structure
or the semantics of this abstract
category
remember when we said that true
intelligence is about casting previous
knowledge and new information
into new situations the kaleidoscope
effect
which francois charles mentioned a few
episodes ago
let's go one step further in breaking
down the jargon
the six most important words that you
can wrestle with in today's
conversation are intention spelt with an
s
extension reasoning knowledge
semantics and understanding
behind the scenes we actually spent
hours and hours debating
the semantics of these definitions which
gives you some idea of how complex it is
intention spelt with an s is the
internal structure of an object
it describes all the aspects of some
object while
the extension is just one attribute
usually the output
for example consider the following two
statements the tutor
of alexander the great maps to aristotle
or the most famous student of plato maps
to aristotle they both have the same
answer or the same
extension but the intention is different
this is really important because in most
cases statistical models either ignore
the intention entirely or only
approximate a latent and brittle
representation of it
the intentional attributes are the
building blocks which can be used to
extrapolate new knowledge
and understand how a particular answer
was derived
the intentional attributes are the core
cognitive primitives required
to construct and extrapolate new
knowledge in future
novel situations given a tiny little bit
of experiential
information intention is about
understanding the deeper reality so you
can generalize it better
extension is just the result of some
computation
but we don't know how the answer was
derived
reasoning is the act of deriving new
knowledge from prior knowledge
given new information using logical
axioms
and rules for example if i told you that
my personal trainer had been milking me
you will reason that i've been spending
too much money on personal training or
at least i hope that's what your reason
it might just be
simple deductive reasoning or it might
be abstract reasoning
which amounts to extrapolation
what about knowledge knowledge is a
justified
true belief true means it's a fact
justified means that it's been
established or proven
this is distinct from data which could
be almost anything and information which
is just curated data
knowledge is the gold standard at the
top of the pyramid what about semantics
people often argue over semantics when
they pick apart the meaning of an
utterance to draw a different conclusion
if you try to get a clear definition of
what semantics itself even means
you might have a fierce debate on your
hands most people will tell you that
it's only relevant in the context of
linguistics
but that's not true semantics is about
the interpretation of
or mapping to an inner structure
to assign meaning think of semantics as
the raw building materials of meaning
the bricks and mortar almost anything
can have meaning
an image for example everything has an
infinite inner structure or set of
attributes
these are the bricks and mortar for
example
a string has a length how many a's are
in the string or how many b's are in the
string
given a situation you interpret the
meaning of an utterance
by selecting the relevant attributes the
relevant bricks and columns
to construct your meaning any object has
the structure or building materials
which can be selected to build the
interpretation or the meaning
the building materials and the possible
meanings are both
infinite this goes back to chomsky's
conception of universal grammar
he said that everything is embedded in
the structure
you can't get something from nothing so
syntax is the inner structure
semantics is the content or what the
structure is saying
or what it means and for the sake of our
purposes here you can think of the
syntax or the inner structure
as being the same thing as the intention
spelt with an s what about understanding
understanding is successfully
ascertaining meaning
by reconstructing the original intention
or that inner structure
from the syntax and any prior semantics
that we have
it allows the derivation of all of the
possible new semantics
we understood what was presented if we
can describe and reapply
the knowledge gleaned for example the
beer
fell off a table and splashed on the
floor a person who
understood that utterance could from the
semantic map of the sentence and
probable world models
derive that now the floor is wet the
floor is slippery
and people might fall down on the floor
all of which
are new semantic maps from those new
sentences
to an updated world model now deep
learning models they don't explicitly
learn the inner intentional structure
or not robustly um i mean i do kind of
learn it to some extent you know they
might have a latent dimension for fur
on an animal for example but discrete
problems or problems which require
few shot extrapolation or abstract or
step-by-step reasoning
are bad for deep learning because no
smooth learnable latent manifold exists
for these problems
deep learning models can only generalize
for interpolation on the surface of a
learned
latent manifold mostly representing the
statistical regularities of the
extensional answers not the core
building blocks or the semantics
neural networks are giving you a fish
whereas
semantics are teaching you how to fish
now you see i just used a metaphor there
didn't i
metaphors are the cousins of analogies
it helped you understand didn't it
by abstracting the information i allowed
you to apply
your existing knowledge to a new
situation in experience space
this is what we need ai systems to do to
reapply
existing knowledge in future novel
situations
using abstract analogies the only
potential problem is that some analogies
are cognitively laboring and they might
not be understood by people
so there's always a balance of the
information conversion ratio
of an analogy and the reliance on common
knowledge and cognitive processing on
the other end
to make sense of it now the problem with
language
is we don't yet understand the universal
intentional
or primitive logical structural building
blocks of it not in a way which captures
all situations
does this lingua universalis actually
exist
surely it must do right the tragic thing
for us
is that a four-year-old kid can
extrapolate using language semantic
primitives
but we haven't yet built an algorithm to
do the same thing
i recently read an article on linkedin
which highlighted the lack of
understanding of intention versus
extension by deep learning folks in my
opinion
someone thought that they had used deep
learning to learn
learn the discrete fourier transform the
discrete fourier transform can be
thought of as a matrix multiplication
where all of the cells in that matrix
are a function
computation computation is a complex
exponential
which deconstructs your signal into well
onto the complex unit circle
representing integer oscillations of
different frequencies using
sines and cosines
if you visualize this matrix it looks
like a pretty picture which has
all of these concentric and overlapping
circles on it
so this chap formulated an optimization
problem to
learn the dft by randomly initializing a
matrix of
of values and optimizing with stochastic
gradient descent
on the squared loss of the real discrete
fourier matrix and his lend matrix
surprise surprise it quickly converged
to the values of the discrete fourier
matrix
now did this guy actually learn
the fourier transform or did he just
learn the values of the fourier matrix
because if you think about it it was
only learning the extensional
answers it wasn't learning the
intentional structure
of that discrete fourier transform the
model has no idea how to re-derive those
values from first principles
this might be pointing out the obvious
but nothing the model learned could be
used to help it learn
a conceptually similar problem so
if we change one of the coefficients on
that dft
formula even by one if we if we changed
n by one
then nothing it learned would be
transferable right
you'd have to train the model again from
scratch and this is exactly the same
reason why gbt3 doesn't understand how
it arrived at an answer
and it can't abstractly reapply any of
its knowledge
in a new situation so the main thing
that these models are missing at the
moment
is the ability to abstractly reapply
knowledge
this is really what we need so the guy
who wrote this article he went one step
further and he learned the fourier
transform via reconstruction
which is to say not using an explicit
fourier matrix even to test against
only testing using the squared loss of
the original signal against the
reconstructed signal
but when he reconstructed the signal he
basically used the signs and the cosines
of the original signal to do so so he
biased the model by baking in the
intentional knowledge and the fourier
transform into the optimization problem
itself so
what would rich sutton say about that he
also
unwittingly created a symbolic model
i think this misunderstanding is a
pretty good analogy for
what is going on in the deep learning
space at the moment
professor rich sutton said that we
should finally learn our lesson
and recognize the appeal of what he
thinks
are our mistakes which is to say
building systems the way
we think we think doesn't work in the
long run
he thinks that building knowledge into
our systems works
kind of good in the short term but
reaches plateaus
in the long term and actually inhibits
our progress
he thinks that progress comes from
scaling computation through searching
and learning well i think i agree with
him actually i mean
if he's pointing out that our knowledge
should not be hand crafted then
you know god yeah in my opinion this is
the most obvious bottleneck imaginable
every single time in my career when i've
been working with human knowledge
engineering it's been a disaster
the term knowledge acquisition
bottleneck was coined for a reason
in my opinion sutton is an anti-nativist
anti-nativism is the theory that
concepts mental capacities and mental
structures
are not innate and required by learning
it's the it's the ultimate belief in the
blank slate basically an intelligent
system is one which can dynamically and
efficiently
discover new knowledge for increasingly
abstract analogies
the more of a conceptual stretch the
higher level of intelligence
is required arguably it's automated
knowledge acquisition
rather than robust ai which is the
biggest challenge that we have right now
a four-year-old knows that the larger
than relation is transitive
how is that i think people
misattribute the bitter lesson as being
an argument
for big data actually it's an argument
against human crafted
and human introspected knowledge
the biggest knowledge base experiment
today is the psych project
created by doug lennon it was started in
the 1980s and it has over one million
rules
in an epic common sense knowledge base
pedro domingos referred to the project
as a catastrophic
failure even the most notorious gopher
advocate marvin minsky
he concluded that for each different
kind of problem the construction of
expert systems had to start
over again from scratch because they
didn't accumulate common sense knowledge
he said that unfortunately the
strategies that were most popular by
ai researchers in the 1980s had just
come to a complete
dead end saturn also points out that the
actual contents of mines
are tremendously irredeemably
and endlessly complex he thinks that
attempts to model or conceptualize human
minds using symmetries or objects
or space or even multiple agents are
flawed
he thinks that we should instead only
build the meta methods to capture this
complexity
prototypically which is to say only in
its potential
critically he thinks that we should
build what we would call
emergent ai you know so um it can
discover
like we can rather than have us tell it
what we think we have already discovered
so in some sense i agree with rich
i don't think we would understand the
structure of an ai system any more than
we would understand the workings of our
own brain
but there's a good argument that common
sense knowledge is or could be universal
so it seems pointless to relearn it from
scratch every single time
what i think gary marcus is 100 correct
on is that
for us to create such an artificial
intelligence from computers
would involve symbols discrete world
models and discrete extrapolation
but i think the answer lies in a modular
architecture
which will likely be discreet first in
my opinion
involve neuro discrete program search
and involve
neural networks and other continuous
models as perception modules
the system must also possess these
meta-learning priors that charlay
mentioned
in his measure of intelligence allowing
it to consume prior knowledge
and derive new knowledge and reason over
that knowledge
when a self-driving car arrives in a new
city with a holiday parade
it needs to rapidly adapt to the new
situation
rich's bitter lake article might seem
insightful at first but there's not yet
an existence proof
of a reinforcement learning system which
works well on open-ended domains
right which learns efficiently and which
generalizes
rich and his friends just released a new
paper called reward
is enough the premise of the paper is
that
simply maximizing a reward indeed any
reward
given a sufficiently complex environment
is all you need
to develop strong and general
intelligence
in a similar vein to the bitter lesson
they think that
the agent will learn all the skills it
needs
even things like exploration and memory
it's all an
extension of the idea that humans should
not preconceive
how they think intelligence should be
architected at a high level
the root of why they can get away with
shenanigans like this is their
definition of intelligence is
in my opinion wrong frankly the paper
would have been visible had it not been
written by the godfathers of deep
reinforcement learning
their definition of intelligence doesn't
even consider efficient abstract
generalization
or analogy making which according to
douglas hofstadter and francois charles
it's the absolute core of cognition this
is a clip of douglas hofstadter
talking at stanford if we are going to
make any connection between
analogy and a geographical situation
we're going to liken it to the
interstate freeway system
and it links everything together analogy
is the interstate
freeway system of cognition it is not
one little tiny
zone somewhere off in the side it's
so that's uh that's a kind of a a way of
that i think about it i mean i don't
really usually think about it that way i
made that up yesterday so
but it gives you the flavor
categorization is the name of the
cognition game
but analogy is the mechanism that
creates or that allows categorization to
happen
by categorization i mean uh deciding
what something is what the essence of
something is
now one could sort of summarize this in
a corny
little analogy again analogy is the
motor of the car of thought
and then we then can even write it down
as this
little thing analogy is to thinking as
a motor is to a car a is to b
as c is to d analogy making is the
perception of common essence between two
things
and then a couple of footnotes to sort
of hedge
um i mean things don't have essences
but what i mean i'm not a you know i'm
not talking about some kind of abstract
glowing philosophical essence
i'm talking about the essence that you
perceive at the particular time
in the frame of mind that you happen to
be in and uh and by
when i say things it's tempting to think
that the analogies are between
the things in the external world but i
really want to say that analogies happen
inside your head so that they're
they're they're connections between two
mental representations they're
connections between things inside your
head
uh which we project to the outside world
and we say these things outside out
there are analogous and that's very
reasonable to do most of the lineage for
this reward idea can be traced back to
shane legg and marcus hutter
i'd love to get them on the podcast by
the way so if you if you know them
please invite them on i think we'd have
a great conversation and they're pretty
cool
pretty cool guys but um in 2007 they
released this paper called
universal intelligence the definition of
machine intelligence
and it quickly became one of the
articles of faith for modern deep
reinforcement learning um
certainly by the the folks at deepmind
and many practitioners
um their conception of intelligence is
basically
an agent being able to gain a reward
consistently and summed up over the
space of all of the computable
environments
and inversely scaled by the complexity
of each environment
conveniently their conception doesn't
consider prior knowledge
or experience or the information
conversion efficiency or generalization
we already know from the shortcut rule
that you get exactly
what you optimize for at the detriment
of everything
else if kenneth stanley was here right
now he would have a field day
if you haven't already by the way you
should check out the episode we did with
kenneth stanley it was
my favorite episode of the show i mean
a reward is just an objective at the end
of the day
stanley hates subjectives because of
deception
because they're convergent and because
of the shortcut rule
it might be a slightly cynical reading
of stanley's work but
at the end of the day stanley
effectively figured out that
clever objectives which is to say
objectives which are
impervious to shortcuts
deception and convergence he honed in on
interestingness and its proxy objectives
novelty diversity preservation meta
learning
new objectives and information
accumulation
all of which could be optimized
monotonically actually chalet figured
out the same thing in a different way
right
the only objective in intelligence which
can be optimized monotonically with no
shortcuts
is the generalization efficiency itself
we already know that you can't optimize
monotonically on a reward signal without
deception
why do you think there's an entire
literature and reinforcement learning
about exploration
honestly i think the reward is enough
paper is is just complete
madness this is francois charles in
order to build
a general intelligence you need to be
optimizing for
generality itself so intelligence which
is to say
generalization power is literally
sensitivity to abstract analysis and
that's in fact
all there is to it if you have a very
high sensitivity to analogies you will
be able to extract
powerful abstractions from little
experience so anyway
this takes us full circle the story of
intelligence started with minsky in the
70s who thought that intelligence would
arise from
kind of compiling several statically
coded task-specific programs
in the 80s the story evolved to the
current position which is that
intelligence lies in general learning
ability you know being able to acquire
new skills through learning
this is still the dominant view now but
we're seeing hints of the next
generation of intelligence which is
being able to efficiently learn new
tasks
or acquire new knowledge using what you
already knew
with abstract reasoning we should also
realize that with intelligence
the substrate and the context is
important neural networks will never be
able to extrapolate
and will only ever achieve at best a
glitchy representation of discrete
problems
intelligence itself might also be
embodied or better thought of as
an emergent process which is far bigger
than any individual brain anyway i
really hope you enjoy the show today
we've had so much fun making it
remember to like comment and subscribe
we love reading your comments
and we'll see you back next week welcome
back
to the machine learning street talk
youtube channel and podcast
with me dr tim scarf my two compadres
mit ph.d
dr keith duggar and dr yannick
lightspeed culture now our guests today
are so
incredibly accomplished as scientists
and entrepreneurs that
i could probably spend about half an
hour just enumerating their numerous
and impressive achievements but here we
go professor gary marcus is a scientist
best-selling author and entrepreneur
he is founder and ceo of robust ai
and was founder and ceo of geometric
intelligence
a machine learning company acquired by
uber in 2016.
now kenneth stanley who's one of my
heroes of ai was also one of the
founders of geometric intelligence
alongside gary which is super exciting
by the way gary was also listed as one
of the
top 20 most influential people in in ai
last year now um gary is also the author
of five books
including the seminal book the algebraic
mind cluj
the birth of the mind and the new york
times bestseller
guitar zero as well as the editor of the
future of the brain and the norton
psychology
reader now he's published extensively in
the fields ranging from human and animal
behavior
to neuroscience genetics linguistics
evolutionary psychology and artificial
intelligence
often in leading journals such as
science
and nature is perhaps the youngest
professor emeritus at nyu
and his newest book co-authored with
ernest davis is called rebooting ai
building machines
we can trust i also highly recommend you
read his recent paper
the next decade in ai four steps towards
artificial intelligence
we can trust now also joining us today
is professor louis lam
secretary of innovation for science and
technology
at the state of rio grande da sol in
brazil
his research interests are machine
learning and reasoning
neurosymbolic computing logic and
computation
and artificial intelligence cognitive
and neural computation
and also ai ethics and social computing
he was formerly vice president for
research at the federal university of
rio grande assault
in brazil he was dean and director of
the institute of informatics
ex-officio and elected member of the
university council
at the federal university of rio grande
assault he's a member of the programme
of organizing committees of a large
number of
international conferences and workshops
on artificial intelligence
cognitive and social computing logic and
computer science
and embedded systems and formal methods
lewis released his new paper
neurosymbolic ai the third wave at the
end of last year
it beautifully articulated the key
ingredients needed
in the generation of ai systems
integrating type 1
and type 2 approaches to ai and it
summarized
all of the achievements of the last 20
years of research
now one thing i really want to get out
of the show today is moving beyond the
superficial
you know how exactly are we going to
achieve a hybrid approach
conflating symbolic and connectionist
methods let's take it as a given that a
hybrid approach would give us models
which
have caused a reasoning and are more
interpretable more robust and more
secure
gary said in his next decade paper that
without us or other creatures like
us the world would continue to exist but
it would not be described
distilled or understood human lives are
filled with abstraction and causal
description
i think this is so powerful francois
charlay the other week said that
intelligence
is literally sensitivity to abstract
analogies
and that's all there is to it it's
almost as if one of the most important
features of intelligence
is being able to abstract knowledge this
drives the generalization which will
allow you to mine previous experience
to make sense of you know future novel
situations
anyway gary and lewis welcome to the
show it's such an honor to have you both
on here
where are we at with neurosymbolic
methods
uh well first it's a pleasure to be here
it's
good to be in an environment where
people take for granted these questions
because i spent
a lot of the last 20 years almost or
even more than 20 years trying to get
people to recognize the importance of
abstraction
so i i came to this having
worked in psychology on children
learning rules
and came into the first way or second
wave depending on how you kind of
of neural networks and and people trying
to argue that there was no abstraction
that it was all
just basically memorization through
multi-layer networks they were then
three layer networks
and it's been a long hard slog to get
people to realize how important
abstraction is and i
i think that there's been a real sea
change in the last couple of years i saw
um you know correlated with that is a
lot of hype around ai with people who
didn't recognize
how important it is to get abstraction
right and thought well if we just have
you know a billion parameters that would
suffice and in fact
even now you have a lot of naive people
thinking the gpt3 represents more
progress towards language than than it
actually does
so it's been really interesting recently
to see people like yahshua benjio
who were historically fairly hostile to
abstract knowledge and things like that
um say hey we need to have causality in
there of course there have always been
people like
ideoperl who have seen the value and
then to see andrew eng say hey there's
too much
hype in a.i a couple weeks ago kind of
blew my mind because he's been one of
the
the biggest hypesters and he he famously
said you know
uh i i can get a computer i won't quote
a verbatim but i can get a computer to
do anything that a person can do in a
second
the reality is even in a second we use a
lot of abstract knowledge
right we use abstract knowledge about
how the world works in
in order to interpret essentially every
other
so i'm going to defer to lewis on the
state of the art
in large part about kind of technical
details of
um putting together neural and symbolic
things in unified
mathematical formalisms and things like
that i think he knows
better than i but i will emphasize one
thing
which is that it's not enough to have a
technical apparatus to be able to put
these things together and that we need
to look at a larger context
a lot of what the next decade article
was about was that larger context and so
you know there were four points in that
paper one of them was we need to have
hybrids
and i actually cited an earlier version
of the great paper by lewis that you
just mentioned that the recent version
wasn't out yet
um but lewis has been a pioneer in that
but then i also emphasized um
abstraction in general
and you know the value of it which is of
course part of why you want to have
those
hybrid models um and then i emphasized
having large databases of knowledge and
detailed cognitive models
so some of what i still see in the field
is
people working on the technical details
where in some narrow domain i've got an
enormous amount of data and
i kind of crush it with all of that data
but what's really interesting about
human cognition is
we can pick up new domains um with
relatively small amounts of data and
interpret them
people are trying to crush these things
with
large amounts of data but they're still
doing it in this kind of anti-nativist
way where there's no
prior knowledge aside from what is
acquired in the course of that system
and i think if you look at how people
actually
encounter things in the world they have
prior knowledge about domains and they
can quickly assimilate new knowledge
by building a model of what is going on
and by having this rich database of
we'll call it common sense sometimes
it's expert knowledge um
and so for example if you watch a movie
and you see somebody pick up a gun
you know something about what guns can
do it's not like
you're watching 30 seconds of the movie
and then you infer that guns might kill
people you already
know that and you know some of the
parameters like you know
you know the gun might get stuck it
might not be loaded you
might know the meta narrative um i think
it's due to check off
if there's a gun on the table then you
know you've got to use it
in the plot it's probably not just there
for decoration so you use that meta
knowledge
in in the process of understanding
things and i have not yet seen
any really rich reasoning system working
at that level
where it's all integrated the closest
thing is psych which doesn't have the
neural side of things at all i mean i
guess they're adding in a little bit but
it
fundamentally is a purely symbolic
system um
and not a learning system so there's
still lots of things to
put together i think lewis is working at
the foundations of how can you
consolidate these kinds of information
at all and we shouldn't lose sight of
the fact that the larger context in
which we want to do that
is we want to be able to put all this
knowledge together
or right now you know we're doing um a
video or podcast together and so you
have knowledge about like what's
socially appropriate for that
i shouldn't get up and take off my
clothes it's not that kind of video so
you have background knowledge about
etiquette
you have knowledge about what the
audience they want we're on the call
with knows what the audience
out there in listener land might know
and we're constantly integrating
just this huge range of knowledge and we
shouldn't forget that that's
why we want to have the neurosymbolic
integration is to put together
background knowledge some of it's going
to be innate and maybe we can talk about
that later
some of it's going to be culturally
acquired and so forth but that's the
reason that we're doing this
so now i defer to louis to kind of give
you the
technical state of the art on how well
we can do that with any knowledge at all
thank you gary thank you so much for
the introduction too and
we are living at some i would say some
exciting times in ai
one of the reasons uh is not the hype
as gary mentioned but i see that uh
the times we're leaving are exciting
because people like gary
or like postmolinsky and even joshua
benjo as
gary has mentioned have now looked at
what's going on
and have noticed the need for
abstraction the need for
interpretation the need for better
semantics
as gary said we had some very large
language models
that uh look very promising that look
very exciting
when they go into the press the the
media the printed press and so on to the
social networks these days not the
printed press anymore
and people get really impressed by some
of the results
we can mention for instance the example
uh the exercise that the guardian did in
the uk
by editing that small journal piece
last year and the editor said well
i just put the same amount of effort the
same amount of work
that i would dedicate to any kind of
piece that the guardian
publishes so that's the summary of what
the guardian did in some way
however as we have defended here
for quite some time for a long time as
gary said in his brilliant work on
cognitive science and the
the way children uh
reason the way children learn he has
some very
impacting papers on that and some books
that are referenced to us in ai
these days we have to look at the
foundations and also we have to consider
what kind of abstraction in ai
and in computer science by the end of
the day that we have to use we cannot
forget that computer science
was born out of the symbolic school of
reasoning the symbolic
school of logics we we don't need to
mention
alan turing and the pioneers and the
symbolic reason and symbolic ai
has always been at the core of
the kind of developments that we are
dealing with these days
so when we see this kind of uh
disputes or this kind of uh disparities
that uh
or this kind of separations or device
that we see in machine learning
we don't think that that makes much
sense or that
or that this kind of division
contributes to the development
of science in general and of uh ai and
machine learning in particular that
are at the four of this discussion and
um
when you think in terms of the kind of
developments that
we have been looking at over the last
years we are
looking yes for a foundation of
integrated logical reasoning and machine
learning
why this is important well i'm sure that
gary
will mention it later on um when we
develop a system
we in an ai system or a machine learning
system
we don't we do not want only to find
correlations or label classifications or
better interpretation from the label
databases that we have
we actually want to to provide
appropriate semantics for this kind of
inference this kind of
reasoning that we are working on very
large amounts
huge amounts of data and this is only
growing
and however we cannot forget
and uh gary has said that in in several
of his papers we have also defended this
position that formalizing notions like
common sense reasoning
or even combinatorial reasoning that is
more related to the core to the
foundations of
computer science is still a very very
open problem in the field so what we
look at in
neurosymbolic ai is exactly how to
compute
and how to learn with symbols
inside or outside the neural network in
the way that
we can provide a proper semantics to
what's going on
in this very large language models for
instance or in this very
efficient let's say um
image interpretation and computer vision
systems
but we do not have at the point that we
are in ai these days a proper
and a complete foundational semantics
for the field
so what we look now here is how to
provide
a better semantical foundation a better
semantics for
what's going on in machine learning and
also
to explain how the reasoning process
goes on
when one is dealing with this very large
connectionist model with this very large
uh neural network models because we have
to consider that when
when one deals with millions and
millions of labels
millions and millions of parameters with
the number of hyper parameters that one
has to set these days
we look some site of the foundation some
site
of what actually is going on in terms of
rigorous semantic foundation that
computer science
demands from every field so in terms of
what we have achieved in technological
uh impact this has been impressive there
is
no way that we can we cannot recognize
that
however when we see the hype in terms of
claiming that the systems are better at
language interpretation or language
inference
or language understanding or machine
translation or language translation
we are still very very far away from the
kind of foundation that
computer science and ai needs so in this
sense i make a small comparison
a small historical let's say uh
backtracking here in the in the early
60s
at the high of the the space race there
was a lot of investment
in computer science for the for the
reasons that we know we need to
to put a man on in the moon and bring
him safely back
so there was a lot of investment in
terms from from darpa from
from from nato from several bilateral
government agreements in the western
world and there was a lot of
developments in computer science and
computer programming
people needed to program computers much
faster than using machine language or
assembly language
so there was a lot of development in the
60s and one of the
developments that we had in the 60s was
the search for semantics of computing
the search for semantics of
programming language what the program
means what the program was actually
doing
this was extremely important if
one considers and remembers the kind of
harder resources that we have at the
time
we needed to provide a very adequate
semantics a very precise semantics
because
it was a very right uh high risk project
put a man on the moon so we needed
logical and mathematical foundations
and at the time there was this
famous discussion between the computer
science and the
very prominent computer science in the
uk called christopher strachey
who is a named professorship at oxford
university this day
samson abrensk is the christopher
extractor professor of computer science
at
oxford now and christopher strategy was
trying to associate or to
provide the formal semantics of
programming language
using a formal system called the lambda
calculus the lambda calculi
however dana scott was a u.s
logician who who after that spent the
next 10 years in oxford said well you
are doing all wrong the lambda calculus
does not does not provide
an adequate semantics for programming
languages we need to develop
this director semantics a new theory to
provide semantics for
computing so in the end of the day they
were able to provide a
better formal semantics for programming
languages and now
we have very effective programming
languages that were very useful not
only in the in the
let's say during the 60s but also later
on today we know how to
program we give better semantics to
programming languages into the sense of
computing
i expect to see the same kind of
developments
happening now in ai and
in machine learning we need to provide
better semantics better appropriate
semantics
and this kind of results typically come
from
the logic community or the formal
semantics community
come from uh also they get feedback from
cognitive science because we are dealing
with learning here from neuroscience
but we are not at the point that we have
a solid
uh founded semantics for machine
learning and we need that
if we want to provide not only a solid
scientific background to our field but
also
to make sure that people who are
actually using for instance
machine learning tools or ai tools in
medicine feel that this kind of tools
and technologies are
safe to to to massive usage so this is
my introductory
statement i hope we can keep going on on
this subject
yeah i mean definitely covered a lot of
uh territory there and i think
something that uh you know gary marcus
said in the beginning that i find
somewhat
ironic there's there's an irony in the
fact that it took so long
to convince people that abstraction was
necessary i mean after all
they're doing their research using
abstract language they're building
systems
on computers operating at a level of
abstraction far above you know the
the continuous wave functions that are
governing the electrons etc i mean all
around us there is
symbolic reasoning there is abstraction
and this is kind of a bizarre sort of
denialism that this is all actually an
illusion
and not only that but it's not a very
useful illusion that we should just
instead reduce all the way down to
you know continuous kind of kind of
functions but i think a lot of that
that fear or resistance to to kind of
accepting that or the move away from it
hinges on something
uh that professor lamb said which is
that you know we have to be able to
optimize we have to be able to search
the space and kind of find workable
solutions for it
and of course you know we should all
know that that say discrete optimization
problems you know
integer programming etc have this long
history being very difficult
to solve because they have this kind of
combinatorial nature to them
and i think it was um in a debate with
uh you you know professor marcus where
where joshua benjio said oh well
you know i can get uh i can get kind of
discreet reasoning by just having
multi-modal
distributions and you know some type of
sort of interactions between these
you know multimodal distributions but
i'm wondering the closer that they drive
those kind of differentiable systems to
emulate
discrete or symbolic reasoning in some
way aren't they just going to then bring
in
all the difficulties and training and
learning that we see if you try to
just go ahead and operate at kind of a
more discreet
level of abstraction i i think we
haven't fully solved these problems
right so
what we want is to be able to harness
the ability of these large systems to
search large parameter spaces
with all the value that you get from
discrete symbol systems
if what you do is you take your neural
network
and you emulate a symbol system exactly
which you could do we've known how to do
for many years then you're stuck with
all the problems that symbol systems
have had
um you know if all you do is you
emulate you know a 6502 microprocessor
and then you know build the programming
language basic on top of that
then you write spaghetti code and
basically you know you haven't solved
anything
i wish we had the answer right now but i
think the truth is we're sort of like
you know physics pre-newton or something
like that we're missing some basic
ideas about how to wrestle with the
combinatorial complexity of reality
integrate the knowledge that we have
about the world works
with kind of learning systems so um
right now like i could tell you there's
a you know i have a glass of water on
the table
and you can set up in your mind the
semantics of that and louis might want
to say a little bit more about
how he's thinking about semantics but
i'll say as a cognitive psychology that
when i tell you there's a glass of water
on the table
that there's something in your head now
that says
there's a table there's a glass the
glass is containing water
and you know you encode all of that and
now you can do some things like
if you see me flailing around my arms
you might say i wonder if that glass of
water is going to be in trouble and he
might
knock over that glass of water and then
you can make inferences if he did there
might be glass on the floor
there'd certainly be water on the floor
it might make a noise we might have to
pause the recording while he cleaned it
up
and so you can make all of these
inferences and you can do some of that
statistically and the confusion has come
because the fact that you can do some of
it entails in some people's minds that
you can do all of it so
you know if i fed that whole scenario
into gpt3 sometimes it would get
it correct but it wouldn't reliably get
it correct so if i said
um you know he knocks the glass of water
over with his hand and dot dot dot
statistically a likely continuation
would be like and there's water on the
floor and so you'd say hey gpt3
has the semantics it understands it but
when we push these systems you quickly
understand
that what's really going on is it's like
this giant library of cut and paste
um with a lot of synonyms and it's just
very superficial it's not really
building up a representation of where
the glass is where the water is
and so forth um the symbol systems are
really
good at doing that and we've had things
like you know blocks world for years and
years they can make inferences i mean
block's world wasn't perfect might do
but the problem with those systems is
like everything's hand-wired in advance
in the next decade i give this article
of parsing
the story of romeo and juliet with psych
and
if you have programmers who translate
everything in the story
into symbolic propositions and you have
background knowledge like
people when they're dead or no longer
alive like basic common sense but
encoded
well which is what sykes project has
been then you can make great inferences
that are like really high level
inferences about like
what juliet might think romeo's going to
think when she drinks
a fake potion i mean a potion that fakes
her death
right it's like really fancy inference
that people actually can make routinely
like
everybody goes to romeo and juliet and
they understand the dynamic that's going
on of like
different people having different
interpretations and they understand
the tragedy of it all and so like site
can actually
do that but the problem is site can only
do that
when all this stuff is hand wired and we
can't sit around
paying programmers to to you know
pre-wire
every narrative that we might encounter
and so
we need to bring these things together i
think a lot of it comes back to lewis's
point about semantics
the only way forward is to actually
represent the semantics of whatever it
is you're trying to absorb
you know whether it's romeo juliet or my
my moral tale of my glass of water or
whatever it might be
you need to be able to manipulate the
entities that your world is structured
around and to track them
so i tell you there's a glass of water
and there's also a cat on the table now
you think about the cat and that's in
your mental representation
and then you can worry is the cat gonna
knock over on the glass of water and you
make all these inferences
we just don't really have a technology
that can do that in the full we have
technologies that can do that
in the narrow so you know you can
build some kind of well i mean like a
gps
navigation system does lots of
inferences in the narrow right it
understands
you know where the beacons might be it
can make
shortest path relative to some known
constraints
and so forth so we could do this in the
narrow but we don't know how to do it
in the general what's really interesting
is that um
in in the good old-fashioned ai days we
we had
human captured knowledge right and we
had the knowledge acquisition bottleneck
because
i'm a huge believer in the kind of
semantics you're talking about and i
agree that they can
extrapolate a lot better although after
the conversation with charley i was
somewhat convinced that
there's an appropriate um kind of
substrate for an appropriate problem so
you know type
1 might be good for mnist although
interestingly there's a type 2
abstraction for any situation so you
know you can abstract mnist into a
discrete categorization but um i want to
get to the nub
of the difference between the gpt free
fans and what you're talking about
because we spoke to one of our friends
earlier
he was one of these differentiably
minded connectionist you know gpt free
loving types
and uh connor and uh anyway
they think that it is statistics all the
way down and that we perform some kind
of bayesian update to data
you know with experience and they think
that there exists a universal generating
function of the universe and
gpt3 is somewhat akin to this they think
that any symbolic reasoning is simply an
emergent phenomenon
and a form of error correction if you
like and would indeed even emerge in a
larger version of gpthree if it existed
even if this were true in my opinion
it's a bit low down in the taxonomy to
expect our models to memorize all the
permutations of everything
it harks back to the ridiculous
arguments about touring completeness and
universal function approximation and the
need for infinite amounts of data and
training passes
as you cited in your paper you know when
when humans hear the statement about
water leaking from a broken bottle uh
gary they can abstract and therefore
extrapolate that information to work for
ball bearings falling out of the bottle
or dice falling out of the bottle
you know there's something it's
critically important about being able to
abstract information and acquire
knowledge automatically
that seems to be the thing that we're
missing right i mean
absolutely it's what's missing i i i
would say that
you know your friend that you're
interviewed has a lot of buzzwords but
that
there's no connection between those
buzzwords
and a working system at the moment so it
could be that many of those buzzwords
really are part of the picture
so bayesian updating i i'm you know
pretty positive about um
differentiability is probably part of it
i don't think it's the whole solution
nobody's
really gotten all that to work um and
there was another buzzword oh emergence
um and you know it's nice to say things
emerge but like
gpt-3 is a really honest test of
the hypothesis that's been kicking
around for depending on
how you think about it 20 or 60 years of
everything will emerge when i just
eat in enough data i mean when i was in
graduate school jeff ellman was writing
these papers about simple recurrent
networks that in many ways foreshadow
what's going on
right now he's no longer with us i
sparred with him many times
he doesn't get nearly enough credit for
having anticipated all
all of this stuff 20 some years ago the
first thing i did after graduate school
was to have a debate with him uh at
mit um about simple recurrent networks
and the same issues are still kicking
around
um but we have a mind-boggling amount of
data compared to what he was working
with he had like
600 sentences that maybe had handwritten
or not
that he fed into this proto multi-layer
you know neural network and it could
predict certain things about
grammaticality basically so subject-verb
agreement it had its limits some of
which i pointed out or whatever
but um you know we had a little back and
forth but now
you know you have gigabytes of data
instead of like
a few k of data and it's gotten so much
better in some ways and not at all
better in others
so which ways has it gotten so much
better well his system
was like cat drink water it was like
you know it was like telegraphic speech
or
you know that we talk about in child
language literature was nothing like
real language
but he was right to see in that that you
could emulate
language if you had more data and that
you could there were regularities that
you could capture and he did you know
interesting analyses about the
clustering of sentences
and i made the counter argument i said
even when you have these clusters of
sentences
that doesn't mean that the system is
truly abstracted if you have a new
sentence
it's going to have trouble and i i did
some formal demonstrations
in a 1998 paper called rethinking
eliminative connectionism
that he has anticipated so much of
what's going on and you know
one of the things that i said was their
problems with same different there was
just another paper
came out a few days ago i haven't read
yet showing the same different uh
problems in the context of current
neural networks so in 20 years later
even just the basic notion of same and
different is hard
if what you're doing is you're
accumulating a lot of things that
doesn't mean that you have
that they're similar doesn't mean you
actually understand the abstract
principle that underlies them and if i
can just give a little philosophical
um terminology philosophers sometimes
talk about
extension and intention and intention is
i think close to what
lewis means by semantics so extension is
like
i i show you i tell you what a pair is
in cards let's say
and i show you two twos two threes two
fours two fives etc
and you just have the list you look up
in your table um a nine matches
nine great now i know um that's the
extension
of a pair in cards the intention would
be like knowing i've got two cards that
match
and by and large what these neural
networks do is they traffic in extension
things that have appeared together and
clustered together the intention is
understanding that the deeper reality
that is causing it such that you can
generalize it well we're still kind of
stuck there
it's just the extensions have become
massive and so
they become more compelling for certain
things they become more compelling
in this prediction thing but you can
always break them so you know i
i had this example in technology review
with ernie davis where
you're drinking uh cranberry juice and
you're really thirsty you don't quite
have enough you pour in some grape juice
and what happens and gpt3 continues you
drink it which is a plausible
continuation
and then it says you die which is not
plausible because nobody drives from
drinking crayon grape juice right
and so it doesn't really understand the
you know the
toxicology of human beings even though
it pretends like it does when it says
you die
but it doesn't actually understand
anything about those mechanisms and so
the extension
has led it astray in that case because
um there's not much left you're really
thirsty correlates in its database i'm
kind of being a little bit loose here
but um correlates in its database with
sentences about you die so
lots of times when you drink something
out of desperation maybe you die from it
because
you know or in its database like people
tell tales of you know
adventures or who drank the you know the
poison or whatever
um that's that's a fact about its
database and maybe that's another way to
put all of this
is these systems are totally driven by
these kind of idiosyncrasies of database
because they don't represent the
intention just the way with my
pair example like if you happen not to
have had two tens if that's all you did
it was a lookup table
then you're in trouble when you get to
the two tenses you don't really know how
to think for yourself
um and semantics is about being able to
think for yourself
at that level and so you know what's
better is
the the emulation you get from the
extension is so much better because we
have
you know training sets that are
approaching a terabyte and so
you're much more likely to find
something in the extension that's close
to the thing you need
and there are some places where that has
practical value
if you wanted to make an autocomplete
system then that's awesome right it's
going to make
the best auto complete system that you
can imagine but if you wanted to give
medical advice and somebody tried to set
this thing up as a suicide prevention
uh counselor then it's a tragedy right
you know there's an example out there on
the web where someone asked gpt3
or said i want to kill myself and and
gpt3 said i think
um that would be a good idea like this
is not what you want like it doesn't
understand the
the the underlying conceptual framework
of a suicide prevention hotline it's
just randomly putting together a
sentence that
seems to be close to this database and
even with a terabyte
it's not enough so you go all the way
back to um
john locke and the idea was hey
if i just have enough sensation it will
all and this ties
back now it will all emerge i don't know
if locke used that
word i can't remember off hand but but
your friend with the buzzwords is like
it will all emerge when we have enough
data
well no it will emerge when we have
enough data
and we have a formalism that allows us
to put together
the symbolic knowledge with the kind of
large-scale
quantitative data in a way that can
contact
a cognitive model and allow you to do
reasoning over that's when it will
emerge
but that is to say we need a bunch of
tools there that we don't quite have
it's not going to just come out
by magic gpt3 was the test of the magic
hypothesis
put it all in with you know a reasonable
structure
and transformer network and hope for the
best and
what you get is a mess i think the
argument to make of we need abstraction
we need sort of semantics to describe it
all is it's an easy
argument to make but how do you how do
you
being in in this field arguing for this
what's kind of a workable definition of
abstraction
like how do you you know going also here
beyond the buzzword of you know we need
abstraction i
i do abstraction you do abstraction
like when does a system do abstraction
and
what would you accept like if i came to
you and said i have gpt4 and it does
abstraction what would you accept
as a test that that is happening
i think the proper tests aren't being
done right now and
i think there's a related problem that
people have finally gotten wise to
which was actually at the core of the
1998 article
which is about extrapolating beyond a
training space
so the core example that i used there
was actually about same different it was
i'm going to train you on the identity
function for
even numbers of a certain size
and i'll give you some examples and then
there's going to be two kinds of
generalization you can do
interpolations like you've got a cloud
of points i've trained you on can you
interpolate between them
and yes neural networks can do that not
perfectly there's a bunch of problems
but
you know reasonably well um and then
there's extrapolations like i give you
an
odd number and it's represented as
binary in digits
well the odd number is outside of the
extensional space
um it's outside the training space of
what you've seen or the training
distribution
and that kind of system can't generalize
and
humans do generalize or generalize in
this particular way that i would say is
the abstraction kind of way
in the same circumstance so i followed
the 98 article up with a 99 paper
in science with seven-month-old infants
and i showed infants
do the kind of generalization or
abstraction where they treat something
as a class
so i what i gave them was set of
sentences like a lot and i had some
collaborators we i should say
uh my team and i um we gave um
people examples like la tata ganana
um to be of an abb structure let's say
and we'd either give you something
all new words with the same structure
wolfe a
or a different structure woe rothe which
would be an aab structure
and we we balanced a lot of stuff about
phonetics and stuff like that
so that you couldn't just rely on on
phonetic overlap we did
a bunch of controls and the study has
replicated which is not always true
in psychology but this one has um and
what we found is the kids recognized
change um to a new structure over
new material and that's what you you
know that's really the essence of it
that's what it is to generalize
extrapolate
beyond the training uh distribution and
i think that's really what abstraction
is about
it's to say i get it this is identity or
identity over time
um so you know the first one was
identity with the
eve i was literally describing identity
so
f of one one zero is one one zero and
then the second is identity over time
basically so i have
a a b or a b b um and
that is the course to be able to do
something like that of course it's not
just identity in fact
what i described in the 2001 book the
algebraic mind was a whole family of
functions
that i called you quotums um i don't
know if i've ever said the word out loud
or not
um universally quantified one-to-one
mappings u-q-o-u-t-o-m it's been a long
time it's been 20 years
um so so there's a whole family of
things
where each input has a unique output
and it's not that i think those are the
only things you can do with abstraction
but those are the ones
that are most cleanly
just cut away from
the things that you can do with other
kinds of systems so they're the
scientifically
purest case are the ones that require
you to take a one-to-one
mapping every input has a unique output
and generalize that outside the training
space so we can do that so
you can do f of x equals x for any
number you can do f of x equals
x plus 1 for any number x plus two right
there's an infinite number of these
things
you can think of language in the same
way so like
i can add e d to any morpheme and i get
a new past tense so i can say
um you know this is glass clothing and
i'm i've just
glass clothed my laptop i don't know if
you could see it so i've made up a new
verb and you know that you're going to
add ed
um to that thing or maybe it's glasses
cloth and then i've glasses clothed it
and so
you can play this game perpetually you
don't need to have it in the extension
of what you look at and there's a little
cheat having to do with phonetics which
is
which we ruled out to show that it
really is generalization
outside the training space the kids
could do that's
a working definition of a form of
abstraction it's not the only form
but that's the one where the neural
networks keep getting into trouble over
and over again
and it's really foundational there's so
many things that we know
um the latin for it is mutatus mutandus
we know that this thing is true
for you know but i'm going to change a
little so
i'm i'm going to say you know walk is
walked talk is talked and mutatus
mutandus
glass is clothed you know or glasses
cloth goes the glasses cloth
right we know this kind of i'm going to
change it with respect to this
item that's that is a you know pretty
clean version of abstraction
that we don't have an adequate handle on
i mean
there's some technical machinery now
that can do it in little narrow cases
you want to be able to do that
in general i mean here's here's one way
we would know that we're making
progress in ai would be there's any this
huge database
free to which i frequently contribute
money not time called wikipedia which of
course you all know right human
knowledge
that is in written form so machines in
principle could read it
the reality is all the machines can read
right now are the boxes
right so what year was somebody born
what is the population of canada and so
forth
we get machines to do that that's not
hard at all we you know we suck that up
into
google knowledge graph and so forth but
the unstructured text in wikipedia
contains you know much more than any
individual human
knows and we should be able to suck it
up if we really had ai
the way the newspapers tell you you did
then we will be leveraging that we would
be able to use that to like
make advances in material science or
figure out new ways of
manufacturing vaccines or whatever it is
we wanted to do
so there's all this information it's
there for the taking
and the proof that we don't have ai is
nobody has any idea whatsoever
how to actually take that beyond really
superficial things like
um you know playing jeopardy by finding
the title of the jeopardy question that
most closely matches the wikipedia page
because most jeopardy answers or titles
wikipedia
so we can do that but we can't actually
have somebody read this stuff
and figure out how the world works
whereas you know my seven-year-old can
we
read you know wikipedia and learn
something i think this is the key thing
though
i agree with you that abstraction is
it's almost synonymous with
generalization
and you cite the example in your in your
paper gary about the scalar identity
function i think it's a beautiful
example i i cited it on the
the show the other week which is that
you can't generalize even outside of the
training range and you went a step
further
if you train on the even numbers you
can't even generalize to the odd numbers
it's a sorry state of affairs
and as a human we would look at this
it's a bit like an intelligence test you
know
you're just you're trying to find the
obvious pattern that will work outside
of the
um outside of the training range and
maybe there's some occam's razor maybe
there's there's some core knowledge of
prior knowledge that needs to come into
that but to us
it's absolutely obvious what the pattern
is but to a neural network
it's not obvious now charlay i think has
the best articulation of this concept
yet but
i think actually after i read your paper
you were saying pretty much the same
thing many many years before gary
except when i tried to publish it um
just as a brief
historical footnote um one of the
reviewers said i was doing a terrorist
attack on neural networks
it was not relevant well no i think
what's fascinating about this is is the
concept of
um so the brittleness depends on the
type of the problem
right so you know neural networks are
brittle for computing the digits of pi
and symbolic methods are brittle for a
computer vision task like
mnist so you you make the argument gary
that we need to have a heterogeneous ai
that kind of
enmeshes these two things together and
another thing i noticed reading both of
your papers is that i mean you get a lot
of um flack gary but
i think you're a moderate you know the
kind of recommendations you're making
are already normal you know i mean if
you look at a lot of
undisclosed hybrid methods like alphago
or even gpt3 in my opinion has a
discrete input a discrete output a
discrete search
on the top of it you know so these are
um continuous models in the inner loop
with a kind of discrete search or some
kind of discrete concept in the outer
loop
we're already in the paradigm of hybrid
models aren't we
you know i wrote this other paper we
haven't mentioned
um in 2018 called deep learning a
critical appraisal
and the take-home message was that deep
learning was one tool among many
that we needed hybrid models and eric
bringyoffsen
the economist who i think has done the
most for sort of thinking about
consequences of ai
immediately tweeted about the piece and
he said that you know
it was really provocative and jan lacoon
um
flexed his weight and said well it might
be provocative but it's mostly wrong
and then his followers all attacked me
on twitter you can go back in
into the archives um everything that i
said in there i believe
is now actually received wisdom three
years later so i i was
brutally repeatedly frequently
attacked for it for saying that
these systems don't abstract very well
that there's a real problem
with extrapolating beyond the training
data that
replicability was a problem that there's
no real semantics there
um etc i don't remember all 10 off the
top of my head
um i think all of those are now actually
received wisdom they're now in fact if
you watch
benjio's recent talks they're basically
the the introduction
to his talks are those things that i
said and
you know lacoon has turned around and
you know
even a year ago i was attack or a year
and a half ago i was attacking
gpt-3 and or two excuse me gpt2
saying that it doesn't reason very well
and he tried to say you're just talking
about number problems i said no it's a
more general problem
um and he said well you're fighting a
rearguard action we solved this at
facebook three years ago and he posted a
link
and then i could never even get the
source code um uh
for the paper and i mean it's not solved
and now so even he is actually turned
around
and he he's the one who brought to the
world's attention the gpt-3 suicide
example so he is now
you know kind of he's all about common
sense and how
the these big language models don't cut
it so even like
my fiercest critics have actually turned
in the last couple of years
the iannick said it kind of amused me a
minute ago it's easy to make the
argument about semantics well no it
wasn't for 20 years
every time i made it i was accused of
being a terrorist and a bad person
whatever so it's not easy to make that
argument it's easy to see it in
hindsight and i always think of the leos
silyard thing about the three stages of
scientific truth which is
it's wrong um it's not important
and we know it all along but we do need
both approaches so
um they're written a lot of data coming
back to what you said
uh for a second it is actually the
moderate view to say that
there is wisdom in these two traditions
there aren't always so
you know creationism versus darwinism
i have no patience for creationism i do
not think there's wisdom in that
tradition
sometimes when two sides see some value
one of them i think is just off i don't
i don't think there's any you know
there's a kind of emotional wisdom maybe
in
patience but there's no reality to it
scientifically
but a lot of times when two different
sets of people
see value in two different things that
are trying to approach the same problem
there
is actually value in both and that is
the case here
going back to 1940s um
there has been clear value even earlier
on the symbolic side there has been
clear value in
symbolic computer science right all of
the world software pretty much is still
built on it
you read these like press releases about
how we're going to get rid of
programmers in favor of machine learning
but this is
i won't say it's but it's it's
really far from reality
that is not how you build a browser or
a web app or what i mean sure you you
might you do perception with
a neural network but the basic logic of
your system is in logic
you know every computer language is just
logic so you've got people who said hey
this stuff might be really valuable for
ai
and they're right and then you've got
these people that say
there are these problems that are not
amenable to that because there's all
this kind of statistical stuff that
isn't
naturally captured although you can't
actually integrate in the symbolic stuff
um and you know there's this other way
of thinking about things and it's really
good for pattern recognition
and they're right you know going back to
mcculloch and pitts and and
um rosenblatt and and so forth like
rosenblatt was right he built a neural
network
it was featured in the new yorker in the
1950s it said it was going to change the
world
and it kind of did you know 65 years
later so like there's something to both
of those traditions but
because like grant money is at stake
people have been
kicking each other for years and years
saying no give me all the grant money
don't let my friends
have it they're doing something
different and so there's been this
hostility
for literally 65 years that has not
served
the field well and so like people like
louis are trying to like
step beyond that and say yes there's
something here but there is this
historical context where
people want you know their students to
get the money or they want the
you know the grant to get the big jobs
or whatever it's
led to this incredible amount of
hostility and then
you have people like hinton who once saw
the value
of the integration and then saw the
value of
like the hype and the i don't know i
shouldn't
dig too much into him but he wrote a
great book lewis can tell me the year
um or i can try to get in 1989 or
something like that
um on neurosymbolic integration it was
an edited volume
i think for the journal artificial
intelligence and then in recent years
hinton has had no patience for the
symbolic side at all saying
we don't need this his recent paper glom
which actually said some nice things
about
the tech review is really interesting
but it's like
bending around in in crazy ways in some
ways in order to not use symbols so the
the question that the glom paper is
really trying to deal with is
how do you get a network to uniformly
represent parts of things
well the obvious answer is to use
symbols and label those parts
which is you know i mean has in some
parts of the world been useful and he's
doing everything he can to avoid
doing that and maybe there'll be some
success there i mean as he says at the
beginning of the paper
this is like a theory and not a model
it's not actually an implemented model i
think it's the first sentence of the
abstract or something
um but you know i actually think it's
interesting to try to think through
those questions because
none of us have the answer right so
looking outside the space of the answers
that we have
is the only way to succeed the the space
of answers we have is not
adequate it just isn't and so we gotta
look somewhere else and so i
i admire him for trying to do that
and not getting sucked up in the can i
beat endless
you know by another tenth of a percent
or imagenet by another
tenth of a percent which is what most of
the research does it does not
take us to what is the new idea here
that that we need and so
um you know i like the paper in that
sense on the other hand
i think it's tying itself into not
saying i don't want to use symbols here
and he's got this like very weak
paragraph at the end i sent him
fan mail for the first time in my life
and i said i agree with every
everything in the paper or i find the
whole paper you know really provocative
except of course i do not believe for a
minute the argument you gave against
symbols which was hardly an argument at
all i can't even remember
what it was but um so you know he's
still like pushing with all his might to
try to exclude the symbols
and i don't think you know there's value
in that any more than i think there
would be value in the symbol of saying
you know give us us big computers and we
too
will you know succeed and we won't need
the neural networks we actually need
both
and we need ideas that we don't have yet
i absolutely agree yeah absolutely agree
with uh gary
on this point that we need both so tim
that is the moderate view is that we
need both
lewis and i are the moderates but we're
not viewed that way i mean we were
viewed as like you know
tankers curmudgeons holding on to the
past um we're not viewed as the
moderates who are trying to like
you know find room for everybody it it's
all extremely sensible
as i said when i was surprised actually
but i do want to stress though
that there is a if intelligence is
generalization there are
types of generalization and abstraction
which you can only achieve with neural
networks i mean just look at the
manifold of human faces for example
try and create that generalization for
one second
um for a visual you you do this like
kind of mtv style right
video style you're going to cut it
together um there's a
there's a maybe i can dig it up for you
a headline
of uh reporting the bengio debate that
says gary marcus is the villain ai never
needed
you you should uh throw that in there in
some way
excellent it's a cool title to have
right
i mean like that's something that's
something you write on like
on like your autobiography going back
from the past a bit to the future
and and lewis what you said before
talking a lot about
kind of um we need semantic lo sort of
semantic
the ability to semantically describe
what we're doing
and so on if i think of today
really getting down to how do i
implement a neural network
right i say here's my input data right
and then i do keras or something i
import some module i do layer layer
layer layer layer
right and then i put a loss function i
put an optimizer
and i run go so
in in your in if you can if you can
outlook to a world that you would like
to see
um how do we need to change this
in order for us to be able to better
semantically describe
what we want to do with uh with these
systems
that's a very good point yannick um let
me mention something about uh
relations and uh what's going on in
terms of
what you said in a very simplified way
we touch
we touch on this point in our paper we
have this
so-called embedding techniques these
days
we mentioned it in in our paper so we
wrote about it
where one transforms the symbolics
representations into vector space
but this is for implementational
purposes we just discovered i don't know
if
gary agrees that it's very efficient to
use tensor products and
so on and linear algebra
and this kind of algorithms that have
been uh very effective
okay but this is a uh this is an
implementation strategy
as i say this is not uh this is not
proper
um a proper semantic foundation for deep
learning
the promising the approaches that people
use these days technically
they have the so-called embedding
techniques where they seek to
to translate the the symbolic
representations
or the the symbolic information to
vector spaces where
the reasoning process or the the
implementation of what
of what people call reasoning takes
places
via matrix computations over distance
functions
and in this systems um
the embedding let's say is carried out
using back propagation typically or some
form of uh
modifications of back propagation who's
which is still very popular
it's which is still used these days and
in this way what people are seeking is a
kind of a
manual translation or manual way of
representing
relations in a distributed neural
network
in a distributed neural network that is
seen as
tensors or matrix computations and so on
another thing that people are doing
these days that perhaps
perhaps i say perhaps will shed some
light
in how to to have better abstractions
is that people are starting or are using
the
so-called graph neural network models
but in the end of the day
a graph can be seen as a relation
right you can translate uh graph
knowledge or graph neural networks
into relational forms and relational
forms or relational representations are
in the end of the day
uh a form of uh predicate logics
first order logics and then this can be
translated or this can be
related to the kind of work that people
did
for 40 years 40 years
in databases in relational databases so
there has been some very interesting
work
by alon halevi from uh facebook now he
used to be at the university of
washington
in seattle he came from the database
community from the foundation
of database community using data log
which it's a kind of
extension of prologue to deal with
databases
and he's now analyzing how to build
these neural
databases this uh deep learning
databases and so on
so i in this sense i'm kind of
optimistic
in seeing that people are noticing the
connections
people who works on the foundations of
science and foundations of
ai and these people are very very
serious people that
they have a lot of respect for the
symbolic world they are seeing and
analyze the connections that we have now
between say matrix computation linear
algebra
tensor algebra graph neural networks and
relational work and the relational work
in ai
and when one looks at relation
relational reasoning
that is the the reasoning and the
learning that people are after
in ai even in deep learning people want
to discover relational
information want to discover uh
relations between objects in scenes in
movies in language
in image interpretation all this
machinery all this formal background
is in symbolic ai you cannot ignore that
when you look at the history of computer
science as gary said
even mcculloch and pizza when they
provided perhaps one of the first
neural network models one of the things
that they shown in the paper
was how this kind of networks they
proposed carried out boolean reasoning
logical reasoning if you look at the
paper gary right
and they were cognitive scientists right
they were looking at
the forms that neural networks could in
the future perform
logical reasoning they were let's say
the first neurosymbolic
area the first ones that were
neurosymbolic were mcculloch and pete's
who are let's say the the forefathers or
the godfathers of neural networks
if we have the sense or the the of or
this definition
so what i see now is an opportunity
for people to realize that it doesn't
it doesn't make sense to say that
symbols are useless because they are not
we just celebrated 50 years of perhaps
the most influential paper in the
history of computer science
which was the paper by stephen cook on
np completeness
the beginning of may was when the paper
was published
can we ignore symbolic computing in
computer science absolutely
not are we going to prove that p equals
np
using uh deep learning techniques
probably not we are going to use
symbolic machinery we are going to be
to you to be used uh to use um
combinatorial techniques combinatorial
reasoning common sense reasoning
in building the proof's inference
and so on so i i can i don't see the
reason to be a divide
i follow i'm very happy that some people
from cognitive science some people from
the symbolic ai world and even some
people that come from theoretical
computer science
are starting to work in this field and
analyzing the connections between
symbolic reasoning and machine learning
symbolic reasoning
and connectionist models deep neural
networks
we can also look at the work from people
like as i mentioned alon halevi uh
people like martin growie who is
analyzing the the logic
underlying graph neural network models
which are
quite popular these days and highly
effective in representing
some combinatorial problems and learning
about combinatorial
problems and so on so i believe
that in in a few years time
maybe five years we'll have a much more
adequate
relationship between the communities
let's say where people will respect more
each other
right and we're also going to see more
and more connections
between the results that we have in the
in databases and the results that we
have in database theory the results we
have in
in logic in computer science logic
and the the the results that we have in
deep learning
so in this sense i i never saw the
reason for this
sometimes very not very kind debate
between the two communities
and i believe that computer science the
way computer science was born if you
take for instance the work by john
mccarthy the work by
alan turing and the work not to mention
the work that the cognitive science
mcculloch and pizza
did already in the 40s the symbols were
there
i think one day a social psychologist
really should examine
kind of the history of this this
acrimonious
uh relationship because i mean you know
to professor marcus's credit
uh we've been reviewing all this
material right in preparation for today
and he's been very consistent and one
thing that i think was quite
disingenuous of some of his opponents is
not only do they
really try to stay out of his side of
the field
you know at all possible contortions uh
but they also move the goal post to kind
of
subsume like his his area and now claim
it's what they've been talking about you
know
for kind of all along right i think
that's that's quite disingenuous
but you uh you mentioned a trigger word
for me which is sort of
np you know the the problem space of uh
mp completeness
and you know this the space of mp or mp
hard problems
often arise almost all the time when you
have these sort of discrete
problem spaces right like the traveling
salesman where you have to make kind of
discreet
discrete decisions or the three sat
problem or
uh integer programming so again we're
coming back to this duality
right we have kind of almost the wave
particle discrete continuous
duality and and as you both said nobody
solved the problem of how do we do
optimal learning or even efficient
pragmatic learning
in the space when it involves this
discrete sort of symbolic paradigm
i'm kind of wondering what you both
think right now are the most promising
directions for that like we've talked to
some of the the program synthesis
community like sort of dream coder you
know professor lam i know
you have some recent papers on on as you
mentioned like the graph
neural networks i mean i think there's a
lot of options out there are you seeing
any type of convergence
or or areas that we should be spending a
lot more time on that are kind of being
overlooked
right now i think you two wrote a song
about this called i still haven't found
what i'm looking for
um what i'm looking for
is not just i think in the end
let me say a different way um the the
right solution here
is probably going to be both an
algorithm and also a large knowledge
database and i think what people are
looking for is an algorithm and trying
to dock the large knowledge database
question so you know the person who most
went after the large
database question was doug lennon and
nobody
outside of psych is particularly happy
with what he came up with
my view is that he was trying to do
something great he didn't succeed but
that
what he was trying to do is vital and i
wonder
if we had the right algorithm but we
didn't have knowledge in a
machine interpretable form whether it
would be that useful whether we would
even know like maybe even we have it now
but because we try to use it in a void
in some sense
in this very empiricist i'm gonna start
learning everything from the data kind
of way
it never really amounts to that much so
i often think about this paper um by
rich sutton called
the bitter lesson in in sutton's paper
the argument that he makes is
every time we try something big data
wins over knowledge
and i think he is right as a historical
matter that that has been the case
but what i think he leaves out is that
as a historical matter we've only solved
a tiny
fraction of the problems that we hoped
that we would solve in ai
then most of the problems that we hope
that we solve in ai have not been
amenable to
either a knowledge-based approach or to
a big data based approach
so for example the problem of language
understanding is basically
unsolved at this point whatever hype
aside um it's basically unsolved
and it does not appear to be amenable to
big data and in fact i mean this
is another way of making the hybrid
argument it needs something beyond what
we have and so if we had to write
hybrid algorithm but we didn't have the
knowledge to go with it
and the kind of cognitive structures for
how you build mental representations
over time
if it wasn't part of a fuller richer
system
i'm not sure it would make a difference
and i'm not sure we would know
um i'm trying to think of an analogy
here like it could be
that a three-month-old baby actually has
the innate knowledge the right cognitive
system
but they don't have enough common sense
knowledge acquired
through those mechanisms yet so in fact
the three-month-old infant
has the you know one of the best minds
on the planet you know
no non-human will ever match what that
three-month-old is about to do
its potential is enormous but if you
sat there and did psychological studies
you'd say okay great if i do a study
right it has object permanence and
piaget was wrong about that
but you'd also say it really doesn't
understand beans about what a laptop is
for and it doesn't understand
you know how to assemble an ikea kit i
guess it's not
passing my benchmarks let's toss it out
right and
you know you you know if you had that
magic formula but it was uneducated
you'd miss it we really need a full
system
and building that full system includes
going after lennox problem
of what large-scale knowledge you need
to have in excess of the form and how
it needs to go after the problem i keep
talking about but not enough
about which is the cognitive model
problem which is as information comes in
how do you assemble that into a database
so yeah people talk a little bit about
knowledge graphs and stuff like that but
um we really need a rich answer to that
so how do you build
a mental model of let's say the people
that are on this call and their
motivations and stuff like that
um until you have that you might
actually not know it
um you know that you've solved this
other piece of it so
one theory is maybe it's already been
solved
but nobody notices and you could ask
what are the most promising things
i think in general people that are
trying to say how do i use
prior knowledge to affect learning or at
least asking the right question i'm not
sure they're
asking it in the right way but i think
that's the right questions if you know
something about something
you shouldn't just start from scratch
and of course convolution
is the greatest version of that that we
have or one of the greatest versions
i know that the world is orderly that
you know the thing over here and the
thing over there
are likely to be the same essentially
right it is translation and variance
that's a piece of knowledge that we
integrate in a learning system
but we don't have as far as i know a
general answer to that
a bunch of people in physics for example
are thinking about that a little bit in
narrow cases
what if the prior bit of knowledge i
want is that objects move on
paths that are connected in space and
time right so you can't just wink in and
out of existence
the star trek transporter doesn't really
exist right um
that's as an example of a piece of prior
knowledge
that's relatively easily stated every
physicist knows is essentially true
at the medium object level we won't get
into quantum stuff
how do you put that let's say into a
neural network of some description that
is going to watch the world and be able
to tell me
which are the individual entities here
how are they going to leverage that
in their segmentation system let's say
to be able to parse out the world and
understand
paths and stuff like that should be a
solvable problem and we should in 2021
actually have an off-the-shelf
technology where i can
you know somehow encode that knowledge
and then put it into my learning system
i would say i haven't found something
that lets me do that in a
comfortable and general way and so i'm
not satisfied with what's out there
maybe someone's written about it and you
know it's not getting the attention it
deserves
yeah i i think enmeshing the
um the symbols and and the deep learning
models that's challenging but from my
perspective the reason why go5
failed in the 80s was because of the
knowledge acquisition bottleneck and and
the brittleness
i even see this now that there are
companies out there that are building
large-scale
knowledge graphs and there's just never
enough knowledge
you just need more and more knowledge
and and and
it's almost as if the knowledge we
captured before didn't seem to work we
need more knowledge for a slightly new
situation
so the the first problem i mean the
first problem is that
we need humans to capture the knowledge
and i'm thinking well what are they
doing well i think the best way to think
about what they're doing is you know
when you
when you do computer programming and you
do object-oriented design you design
classes and you design
inheritance hierarchies and you take two
objects together and you say what do
these objects have in common well
they're both animals they both have fur
they both have legs and you're
you're designing these abstractions that
generalize really
well and we need to have an ai that can
do that automatically right
yeah i mean going back a sentence or two
it takes a lot of knowledge to
do much of what humans do so you think
about
i don't know a 13 year old watching a
movie they've been on the planet 13
years acquiring knowledge constantly you
know so i
i have a um well soon we'll have a seven
and eight year old i have a six point
nine nine
and an eight-year-old and you know they
spend most of their time
acquiring knowledge of some form or
another you know this week it's chass
and spies those are
their hobbies and so they're learning
like you know what do spies do
and what's a pin and chest and stuff
like that there's sponges
for abstract knowledge and concrete
knowledge knowledge of all sorts
some of it's metrical how do i do a
cartwheel but they are constantly
accumulating knowledge and by the time
they get to the point
of doing many of the things that we
expect you know they've been doing that
for years and years so like why should
we think
that it's a quick fix i don't think it
is i i think
you know it it's gonna be a lot of work
the nice thing about software is
and this was leonard's thesis which
might still be true even though i don't
think he succeeded
um it was it might be worth like you
know
several thousand people hours let's or
people years even
um in order to do this once because once
you've done it
you can percolate it and everybody takes
that argument for granted
in driverless cars they all assume yes
it's expensive
but when we get there the value will be
enormous so it's worth it
and very few people talk about that with
respect to knowledge like
you know n of one lennox the only person
who still kind of says
you know it's really worth it to
accumulate this database and he's been
doing it for 30 years i think he's put
in
1200 person years or something like that
back of the envelope 1500
which is a lot but it's you know it's
not that much compared to
what it's taken to build i don't know
google search is a lot more than that
right and so like it's a lot compared to
what an academic can do in their lab
um or maybe what a startup can afford to
do but it's not
on the global scale that big um you know
maybe a need to do that before you get
any of this off the ground but maybe we
need to do it in a more modern way
using techniques that lennon hadn't
thought about when he started this in in
the 1980s but
maybe it's unavoidable i mean my my
strong suspicion
is that it is a bullet that we have to
bite and that nobody wants to bite it
and so
everything suffers as a consequence
because we what we do
since we don't have machine accessible
knowledge
that would take a lot of work to develop
what we do is we try to trade it off
with these massive databases drawn from
reddit
which you know brings all the kind of
bias and anti-vaxx
nonsense and and so forth with it it is
not actually
distilled enough to really be all that
useful
and you know some ways sometimes the
the harder approach actually turns out
to be the right one
it's like guitar instructors have this
saying um slow is fast and fast is slow
so
the field is taking the fast approach of
i'll get all the data i'll put it in
this big thing
and i'll be there but it doesn't really
work it ends up you know in the long run
it's
not actually taking us to the deeper
answers the slower approach would be
let's do the hard work of one by one
taking some of these important priors
josh kennedy's the only person i know
who's really trying to do this
of trying to take a prior like spatial
temporal continuity and figure out how
would i put that in with the rest of my
system
and maybe if we can figure out a few of
those we can accelerate the process and
it'll get faster and faster
but we might need to do some really hard
work on some basics like that
of you know how am i going to represent
just the
minimal kind of physical reasoning about
the world and psychological reasoning
and you know maybe each one of those
pieces is going to be like a phd
thesis to get one fact and that is going
to be so depressing compared to
i you know raised imagenet by one
percent in six weeks of work by
by you know twiddling this parameter of
connectivity um
nobody wants to do it sure yeah and you
might win a turing award by figuring out
to
incorporate one form of invariance you
know efficiently into
into machine learning i really want to
pull in uh professor lam
on this this question too but i know
that uh i believe professor marcus you
have a hard stop in about four minutes
correct or even
two i think okay thank you so much for
being here
thank you thanks a lot for your
questions
great seeing you professor lamb i just
wanted to follow up so we
we've gotten kind of uh professor
marcus's take on look we've got to
build this knowledge base and also find
ways to incorporate
prior knowledge i'm really curious what
your take is on
on some of the most promising avenues
and perhaps even overlooked
avenues for finding a way to more
seamlessly integrate
you know continuous and discrete
activity symbolic reasoning with
perception
yep that's a good point there's a very
good question
let's say when we think in terms of
relational learning
uh learning this structured relational
domains like
for instance let's think for a moment as
a for instance of a database
sometimes very hard because this kind of
discrete
relations uh technically uh
they lead to to to gradients that are
not very easy to deal with
in uh in neural networks so there is a
lot of challenge in representing
relations because of this technical
uh let's say this technical challenges
that we have to deal with
in neural networks and for instance when
we confront
let's say images uh
or signals they are in a way they are
very appropriate for
for neural networks in terms of pattern
recognition in terms of
finding relations and correlations and
associations
between this this kind of data however
uh when we do if relations in natural
language
it's uh is a kind of data where we find
a lot of relations between
the structure of the sentences in terms
of the the grammatical structure of
language this become this become a kind
of
a very challenging challenging problem
and and this is why many people
have uh have claimed have stated that
in spite of having this uh very
impressive large language models
where is still a long a long road we're
still uh
very far away from having natural
language understanding
uh proper natural language semantics
and someone was saying here how you
define
semantics how we define a formal
semantics for language
and this of course uses uh uses tools
from
from logic use those from theoretical
computer science
and in linguistics and in formal
semantics and in the philosophy of
language
we have to provide an account of the
meaning
of how you compose the parts of
sentences the parts of texts
that's why this is so difficult to do
in very large language models because
you find the correlations you found that
you find the proximity
you find the approximations to kinds of
bits of text that are related to the
queries
but you have no formal definition of how
one thing relates to the other to the
other
so this is one thing that's very hard
and this is a well-defined
research subject research
community as well in in logic and
computer science
but uh that we're not being able so far
to translate the results from this
community
into natural language understanding for
instance international language
inference and in deep learning when we
think in in terms of the the the
successes that
for instance deep mind has had with
alphago alpha zero
they have some symbolic component
it's clear that they have some kind of
symbolic comma
component in their systems and they are
doing
as henry cult said at triply i
2020 new york about a year ago in
february 2020
they are doing some form of
neurosymbolic reasonings in
neurosymbolic learning
and this tension that we have between
learning and reasoning
is attention that has this long history
in computer science
but i also i also like to to to state a
sentence that uh
professor les valiant who is a touring
award from harvard university who
is also a british computer scientist las
valens
has said that while distinction between
learning and reasoning
go as far back as at least aristotle
because when you think in terms of the
syllogistic arguments and the inductive
arguments that aristotle
used more than 2 000 years ago we
already had this tension between let's
say deduction and
induction and induction could be as a as
a could be seen as a kind of uh
learning learning procedure the
interesting thing about semantics
because we speak with waleed sabbah
who's a linguist and he says the biggest
problem in language understanding is
that the problem of the missing text
which is that almost everything that we
mean we don't say
uh so it's it's all very well having uh
the semantics but
but you know understanding seems to be
something
it's another module that we need to have
on top where we reason over world
knowledge and we do a whole bunch of
other stuff so
where does the rubber meet the the road
between that understanding problem and
the semantics that you're talking about
that's a good point we have a lot of
contextual information here
you have to think let's say what i like
about uh
when you look at when we think in terms
of the possible world semantics
it's not very related to that but i'll
get to the point here
is that we you start to analyze the
similarities between
the possible situations that we have uh
in
in the world let's say so in this way
when we are trying to interpret language
and there is a lot of unknowns or things
that were not said
we have to think in terms of how to
interpret uh
the possible world in which this kind of
utters this kind of text this kind of
sentence
was written about so this will be a
component
and and here we have an advantage of
these very large language models because
when you bring a lot of information
perhaps the next step is to bring also
to the fore the context in which this
kind of text was written
historical information temporal
information
about the text about the language that
we are about to interpret
so the advantages here about having a
lot of data
is that not only you bring the textual
information or the sentences the
utterances the
the questions the the or the the
summaries that we have
you also bring contextual information
and so in this way
one could perhaps think in terms of
let's say in a foreign analogy here not
only in terms of a montague semantics
that is very
very classical semantics in natural
language but we also could bring about
perhaps the the kind of models that
computer scientists
brought to the fore that are based on
the possible world models in terms of
branching time in terms of words that
are more similar to the other
words that are related to the other so
if we can bring this kind of information
i believe we are getting closer to
having
a more appropriate semantics and more
appropriate symmetrical models for
for instance large language models or
other tools that will be developed that
we're not can we not we cannot even
imagine at this point
so that's a very good point that you
brought to the debate
and uh another promising thing that i
want to mention here
is that if we think of the history of
deep learning
we say well in the early 2000s i used to
go to the new rips conference
and i remember that when i went to the
new rips that was called nips
conference in the early 2000s and
we once presented a paper in 2003 about
the neurosymbolic
temporal reasoning reasoning about
knowledge and
i remember that one guy came to to our
poster presentation he said look
you are one of the only guys here who is
using artificial neural networks right
at the new rips conference
virtually nobody is presenting a paper
on neural networks at new rips anymore
why are you using neural networks
apparently only you and jeff hinton here
are presenting papers about
artificial neural networks that was just
three five years before
the deep learning revolution started in
the academic community and let's say
seven eight years before
the deep learning revolution came to the
foreign industry and
in media so when we think in terms of
uh symbolic ai or neurosymbolic
approaches perhaps we're at the same
point in history
uh we showed in the late 90s
in the early 2000s that there were
symbolic interpretations
and there were kinds of symbolic
reasoning that could be performed by
connectionist models by neural network
models
i believe that with the recent
developments
in integrating the the hybrid models the
symbolic school and connecting schools
we perhaps as gary said before he left
that
perhaps the the the best results uh
are in some of the papers that were
published yet but we have not been able
to exploit
to their full potential i was listening
to a podcast with thomas mikelov you've
probably heard of him he's the guy who
created the skip grand model and um he
said that
before the skip grand model it was like
the dark ages
in natural language processing right and
there are other perspectives so we know
a lot of linguists and logicians and
they say we're in the dark ages now
that they say that we're on our hiding
to nothing with this vector-based
approach to natural language processing
it's
antithetical to understanding he says
that there are
zero degrees of freedom natural language
understanding is about uncovering the
single human thoughts behind an
utterance it's a binary
it's there you know what i mean um so so
they they think that we're in the dark
ages now
and you are very much a pragmatist and
you're halfway between the two things
because language
to me it seems like a very discreet
problem doesn't seem like we should be
using
vector spaces here at all so what do you
think about this
i think language language and
natural language processing natural
language understanding
and relational learning they are
let's say associated they are related in
the sense that they are both
discrete they are both structured
in a way we know that some people
claim that language is not that
structure but we have a formal
grammar for most western languages let's
say or a
formal semantics or a semantics
understanding
for most western languages let's say so
language in a way
is structured and the structure
sometimes is
very strongly correlated to discreteness
to what
to the point that you are making so in
this sense
the hardness of building uh deep
learning approaches that are very good
at relational reasoning
in the logical sense in the symbolic
sense is akin to the challenge of
building
deep learning systems that can produce
language interpretation language
reasoning in the same way
so these problems are related so what i
believe
what i believe and what i guess here and
i'm not sure because they are both
hypothesis
is that perhaps the neurosymbolic
approach
is promising here because we are much we
have better tools
to translate say the the knowledge that
we have about
language into a neural network into a
neural network model
or we have better tools coming from the
logic world
from the logic in computer science is
cool
we have better ways to build this hybrid
approach
where the network interacts and the
network
provides information or the network
learns discrete structures
so we what we do in neurosymbolic
neurosymbolic ai or neurosymbolic
computing
is not to throw all the data at the same
point
let's say not to feed a very huge very
large neural network with
an even larger amount of data what we do
is
we we do some pre-processing we provide
knowledge and presentation tools to
proper
me to proper design learn a learning
system
where symbolic structure discrete
structures
are first learned by this machine
learning mechanism
and from this learning ability and then
you verify then you do your cross
validation then you use
your statistical approach to validate
what you have learned
so the challenge here is to design these
tools
to combine the discrete nature of
language the discrete nature of
relations and the continuous
characteristics
of the neural network approaches and
what we also have to add here is that we
we do not only have to think about
neural network learning
we can consider perhaps reinforcement
learning as
deep learning has done over the years
they have been considering
reinforcement learning and other
learning procedures combined with neural
learning
to to have better learning machinery
better learning results
and in the end of the day the best
very impressive technological tools that
they have
and i i firmly believe uh
and what we have seen over the years
that if you are able to
to have a better representation for your
discrete structures and you train
your learning algorithms with this
translation that you
bring from the symbolic world into the
neural network world
you have better learning procedures that
perhaps you will be able to
to learn about uh symbols let's say
let's focus on symbols here but also to
learn about logics
learn different kinds of logics and
different kinds of reasoning
let us not forget that we
humans are not very good at logical
reasoning
right we are much better let's say at
perceiving
at uh seeing at uh informally
understanding sentences
at informally understanding information
about our world
but we are not the best at performing
logical reasoning logical inference and
typically if we can
teach our computers teach our deep
learning
machinery or teach our neurosymbolic ai
systems then we probably have one of
we'll probably have we'll probably have
to solve one of our
biggest problems one of the biggest
challenges that is to
provide let's say logical reasoning to
the masses logical reasoning to everyone
logical reasoning to make inferences
about
what we are expecting about the world
not not only in terms of logic but to
analyze hard problems for instance
when you have disputes between companies
disputes among
social groups disputes about
several kinds of problems that we have
in businesses perhaps if we can
feed the the ai systems with a lot of
information
and then to design the proper inference
mechanisms or
making the computers to learn the proper
inference mechanisms that will have the
tools
to provide us with better logical
information about how to take decisions
so that's another advantage of the
neurosymbolic techniques
yeah could i challenge on that a little
bit because you said that human beings
um often aren't very good at reasoning
and yeah by the way because you folks
talk about robust ai being a good thing
but if you're talking about creating
learning agents then in a way it's quite
worrying if they might be acquiring
knowledge and reasoning on
on new knowledge and who knows where it
might go but um
in in a sense you could argue it both
ways right so natural language
understanding is is about
disambiguating out of the 50 possible
meanings of an utterance to
the intended meaning and actually i mean
you know when you say the corner table
wants a beer we know the corner table as
a person
we hardly ever misunderstand each other
it's something which is so
invisible that we almost never
misunderstand each other
but then you could make the other
argument that there are loads of
situations where people really do have
bad reasoning
especially if you're having political
discussions on twitter uh you know god
if only they thought the same as me
what we are able to do uh as humans is
to consider
a small set of arguments when we
uh talk to other people
we typically do not
add a lot of information when we're
dealing with logical reasoning with
formal reasoning
okay however when we are dealing with
one of our fields of expertise
say music or football or any other
field of expertise we have as gary said
here
years and years and years of information
that we have
acquired that we have processed that we
have
memorized that we have revised that we
formed ourselves of beliefs that we have
also
made some belief revisions on what we
used to believe and so on we have years
and years and years of information
about our domain of expertise and this
is a lot of
information that's restored in our
brains in our minds
and of course we we are able to reason
upon
our field of expertise much better than
uh
about other information that we don't
know about
this is related to system one and two
from
uh from daniel kahneman but that he
explains in his book
that we are very able to react very able
to to react to things that we have seen
in the past react for instance to
information that is related to our
survivability like like fear for
instance
and in other situations where we are
threatened
and when you are when we specialize in
some field
we are also very we are also able to
react very quickly
so there is an interplay between system
one and two that are the the quicker one
and the
more reflexive one and so on and however
when we are dealing with logical
reasoning
about new information about new
propositions new statements for instance
that someone makes
at the social network we tend to have
some deductive reasoning that sometimes
is not quite elaborate
because we also mix some information
some contextual information
that we react to to the to the to the
provocation let's say
that we react to the emotions that are
involved in the system
and sometimes we are not able to do the
proper logical analysis of the situation
and to find out uh more information more
data
about to take a decision so we are very
good at doing logical reasoning about
our domain of expertise
but we are not very good to do logical
reasoning
about domains that we are not experts on
and since most people are not expert in
mathematics
in logic in natural language
understanding natural language semantics
we are also not being we have not also
been able to translate this kind of
uh of information this kind of
knowledge about language not knowledge
about the mathematics
to the deep learning systems to machine
learning systems
what machine learning systems were quite
effective
were very efficient or very good at were
to
use a lot of data i mean huge amount of
data
and find correlations find inference
about
image interpretation about the language
inference and so on
from this huge amount of data but we
cannot say
mimicking ourselves that we are that
these machine learning systems are
reasoning paul the data
and are actually giving us um
information that has a solid foundation
about for instance natural language
understanding
so in this way i compare the
developments that we have in deep
learning
to the developments that we have in um
in our formal education people have
people are very good
at their domain of expertise they
accumulate a lot of data
about this domain of expertise and they
can very quickly
respond to questions about football
about music
about uh about impressionism about the
french painting and so on
however when you ask them about other
things other domains of expertise we are
stuck
so when we compare deep learning or
compare the current ai tools
with this situation it's more or less
related to that
it's not exactly related but it's an
analogy that i use for instance
with my students wow white deep learning
systems are very good in image
processing image understanding
finding correlations in images fudging
finding relations in images then i
explain
how labeling works how the basic
algorithms work
and i also explain let's say the
importance of having a lot of data
about a lot of label data of
about particular domains in this way
machine learning system and ai system
will work very well
as for instance when a human expert has
accumulated a lot of data a lot of
information
about his domain of expertise about two
three decades
of working or about of uh about hard
work yeah
do you do you feel that um because i
really want to get to
the root of this is is reasoning a
first-class city you know
we're talking about symbolic reasoning
is it a first-class citizen in the human
brain
do you really believe that or do you
think it's some kind of
it because you know when we when we talk
about it and we we project it as a kind
of calculus
right and and it makes sense in that
domain but do you think it's first class
in our brain
um reasoning is a first-class citizen
but reasoning is also
based on experience is also based on
learning
right for instance let's say let's take
a mathematician or a logician
he has years and years and years of
practicing
proofs over examples he's like a deep
learning
system who has seen like 10 million
proofs
10 million logical complete logical
then he becomes an expert in reasoning
about proofs
reasoning about logics reasoning about a
particular domain of mathematics
his experience comes not only from his
uh
from his biological composition comes
also from a lot of experience
a lot of hard work on seeing patterns
on seeing examples on seeing sentences
on seeing logical inferences
on seeing different proofs in books on
developing
these kinds of proofs either way this is
in a way
reasoning is built in reasoning is a
first class system
but it also depends on how you interact
with the world
and how you draw your own inferences
from the world
of course if you practice less if you
use
less learning algorithms about your
reasoning
uh system that feeds your reasoning
systems
perhaps you are not very sophisticated
in reasoning but the the
depending on uh how much you have
developed your expertise and how much
examples on how many examples you have
done over your life you become better
and better at reasoning
it is a first-class reasoning as
learning is a first-class reasoning
well we we often we often have i think i
think i'm i'm taking this a bit out of
what what keith
usually says is that uh if we look at
the
you know the human brain at a basic
level it is
neurons and and cells and
we all agree that humans do reasoning
right humans well maybe not we all agree
but
most we all here agree that humans do
reasoning
some sort of we can manipulate symbols
in our head
so i think maybe what tim was
getting at is do you do you think
that there is kind of like something
special about the brain there is an
extra module
that we have for reasoning or can this
type of reasoning actually be
implemented
on the substrate on like the same
substrate
that does the pattern recognition um or
are these are these two different things
that's a great question i believe we
actually have
only uh some small
evidence about this thing but the answer
is that i don't know
i don't know how it works because we
don't have enough evidence at this point
at this point so from as far as i
understand from neuroscience i'm not a
neuroscientist but as far as i
understand we don't have enough
evidence about if they are either
integrated or separated
what machine learning people like to
think and and believe is that we have
these distributed representations and
distributed forms
of reasoning going on and this is a good
point this is a good point to
to to consider in terms of uh not only
of
the from a computer science approach but
also from a cognitive science approach
to
to to think and consider that we
actually do
have uh distributed knowledge
representation distributed symbolic
representations and distributed
reasoning going on in
uh in our mind and brains that's a
that's that's a good point that
that needs more attention and needs more
uh neuroscience research to confirm or
to
refute the hypothesis that we have at
the moment so i i
i don't think we have 100 we are 100
sure about
if this is either integrated or
separated or
if it is distributed as many as many
people from machine learning
uh currently believe yeah
so there you know sometimes we kind of
um expand on this question a little bit
uh because
even if even if you leave aside kind of
the
neurophysiology behind we can think just
in terms of
abstract properties you know is there
something missing
from the artificial neural networks that
we're playing around with today that we
could if we just borrowed it and
abstracted a little bit and stuck it in
there
it might open up you know new paradigms
or new capabilities so for example some
people think it has to do with
asynchronous firing of neurons that you
know we need to be able to have kind of
a processing
that can take place in the neural
network so that some neurons can fire
over here
and then actually at a subsequent time
you know influence neurons that are back
further in the network
or having you know mechanisms that can
that uh
sometimes feedback and and mimic like
what the dendrites can do where they can
build up
like a charge if you will that can cause
like a different type of firing so for
example
uh you know maybe you want to have
multiple activation functions
that can trigger differently or even
simultaneously so there's like a lot of
you can speculate about a lot of
different kind of abstract capabilities
that if you could
add them into the artificial neural
networks we have today
might enhance its um computational
capabilities or maybe
increase its efficiency at certain
computational tasks
so i think we're just kind of wondering
what abstract
capabilities do you think might be the
most promising
if any well
there seem to be some very interesting
results coming from for instance from
from this there's no transformer models
that use some attention mechanisms
that have been very effective in in some
applications
uh definitely in sequence modeling
in uh in language too
so this this seems to be promising but
uh since it's
relatively new if you compare these
models with the models that
the the convolutional models that jeff
hinton yeah
used in the early 2010s to
to to let's say to feed the deep
learning revolution
we will need more and more results and
more test beds coming from
for instance from these new
architectures i like the idea
of exploiting extending and analyzing
the graph neural network models
because graph neural network models they
are very good at representing relational
structures
and in this way there are hope for us
that we are going to be able to learn
discrete or restricted relational
domains
that are considerably that they are
harder to
to do these days so uh so keith i
believe that
the architectures that exploit the
possibilities of uh
graph neural networks and as a
consequence
a kind of relational model or relational
neural network that will
someone will come up uh from drawing
someone will draw inspiration in graph
neural networks to come up with some
kind of relational neural network
uh this can be very useful in terms of
uh relational learning
and in the end it might be very useful
in
language understanding machine
translation and having a better
semantics for language because
once you have a relational neural
network or a relational representation
of language
or relational representation of
sentences and texts perhaps
you are we are getting closer to having
a better semantics for natural language
understanding
so um i would uh bet
uh not too much money but i would bet
that these relational models derived
from
graph neural networks are a good avenue
of of
research for the for the coming years
because of their
proper proper representation of
relations and
relations are a very important uh
structure in computer science and in
natural language too
excellent well professor louis land
thank you so much for joining us this
evening it's been an absolute pleasure
it's been it's been uh fantastic thank
you yannick
thank you keith thank you tim thank you
to gary who has
just left us so uh it's been a pleasure
and uh let's stay in touch let's stay in
touch with developments in the machine
learning ai and computer science so it's
been a pleasure
and thank you so much for for hearing
someone
uh far away from south brazil thank you
it's been our pleasure